once upon a time there is a grumpy green
ogre named Shrek movies were made about
this ogre and then fans took to the
Internet to write theories about his
heroic tales boy do we've got those
theories for you today watch until the
end to find out why there aren't any
other orgs and most of the films we
gotta warn you it's pretty dark what
kind of night are you one of a kind
Fiona's original storyline we all know
that Princess Fiona was cursed to be in
human form during the day and in ochre
form at night in the first Shrek film
Fiona says that a witch cast a spell on
her when she was a little girl but
details are vague on which witch
bewitched to the princess whoa that's a
lot of witches so who would do such a
thing to Fiona
let's go back in time to find out
according to Jim hill media in the
original version of Shrek Fiona was born
as an ogre
her parents were horrified and locked
her away in a dragon-guarded Tower you
know because they couldn't stand to look
at her in an early draft of the film
Fiona escapes from the tower one night
and meets a gypsy woman named dama
Fortuna she gives Fiona a potion capable
of banishing her ogre side but with a
catch she can only be beautiful when the
Sun is out however since DreamWorks
scrapped to the storyline someone else
has to be responsible for Fiona's curse
so who is it Isak over at Wat so videos'
believes it wasn't a witch at all who
cursed the princess you know donkey
sometimes things are more than they
appear hmm who cursed Fiona there is no
shortage of witches darkening the skies
over the kingdom of far far away but
besides flying on broomsticks and
throwing pumpkins they don't seem to
have a lot of magical powers the witches
answered to the nefarious
Rumplestiltskin so their powers must be
inferior to his own rights otherwise
they would be in charge so could it be
Rumplestiltskin is responsible for
Fiona's curse it's a ballad theory let's
explore that for a second
we know that rumble Stiltskin has the
power to manipulate and change the past
but he doesn't seem to be able to remove
Fiona's curse
so if Rumple isn't powerful enough to
reverse the curse who is well it's hard
to imagine that any of his pumpkin
throwing witch minions
have been powerful enough to hex Fiona
in the first place so that leaves the
witches out we're gonna have to side
with Isaac on this one he thinks it was
probably the fairy godmother all along
it makes sense she knows everything
about the curse she's a total hex and
potion master and she really wants to
rule the kingdom Kerstin Fiona gives her
a certain power over the king and queen
so the witch who curse Fiona wasn't a
witch at all it was a power-hungry fairy
with a bratty son go figure
it's just a donkey the donkey
metamorphose there's a fan theory about
donkey that is really messing with
people's minds some fans believe that
donkey is really one of the wayward boys
of Pinocchio's Pleasure Island who has
been turned into a donkey you guys
remember that moment in Pinocchio which
is responsible for the trauma and
emotional scarring of a whole generation
of kids right it's the part where the
boys are led astray to Pleasure Island
with the idea that they can do whatever
they want but when they get there they
began transforming into donkeys first
Pinocchio is actually in the original
Shrek movie which means that the
characters from Pinocchio's world are
also instructs world
reddit user Jeremy V doubled down on
this theory adding supporting evidence
to this whole donkey human idea he
pointed out that while most of the
characters in Shrek had nursery rhyme
and fairytale backstories donkeys origin
story is kind of a mystery also Jeremy B
alluded to the time that donkey
remembers getting wedgies and swirlies
in school when Puss in Boots asks him
about how a donkey with no underpants
could have been wedgied donkey replies
that some things are better left unsaid
is donkey remembering his human
childhood
yikes Artie's father at the beginning of
Shrek the third the froggy King Harold
is just about to croak he declares on
his deathbed that Shrek and Fiona are
next in line for the throne shrek thinks
it's a terrible idea for an ogre to be
king
he asks King Harold if there is anyone
else who could take the crown with the
King's final dramatic last breaths the
King tells Shrek that his nephew Arthur
Pendragon is the only other heir to the
throne so Shrek donkey and Puss in Boots
set on the quest to bring Arthur to
far far away but the details on Arthur
aka Hardy's father are vague in the
original tale King Arthur's father is
named Luthor Pendragon but in the Shrek
world many fairy tales and legends have
been flipped on their heads one fan on
reddit has a different story
redditor john call of duty thinks that
Artie's dad is Sir Justin this fan
points to the scene in Shrek - right
before Shrek reads Fiona's diary he
looks up and sees a poster on the wall
of Sir Justin we all know that Justin
Timberlake did the voice of Arthur in
Shrek the third so could this be Artie's
dad what's in a name another Reddit fan
has a theory about trucks named reddit
are expensive MST KS posted that he
thinks Shrek didn't have a name before
meeting donkey he thing said ogre just
spontaneously made up the names Trek
when donkey asks what his name was if he
watched the same Shrek does hesitate
before answering donkeys question he
seems to be thinking up a name at that
moment but why wouldn't he have a name
our augers usually given names by their
parents do okras even have parents
according to Shrek the musical the ogre
definitely does have parents but they
aren't very good ones in the musical
they sent him away when he was seven
years old as his ogre tradition and
instruct the third Shrek tells Arthur
that his folks wanted to eat him they
apparently bathed him in barbecue sauce
and made him sleep with an apple in his
mouth geez no wonder Shrek lack social
skills it's he was possible that his
parents were so busy slathering him up
in a barbecue sauce and playing in his
banishment it probably just slipped
their minds to give him a name we're
guessing he probably didn't have anyone
asking his name before that moment what
would the whole reclusive snarling
terrifying ogre thing
[Music]
an ogre executioner in the first struct
film Lord Farquaad has an executioner
who does all of his dirty deeds on his
behalf
his name is Polonius and he's not
exactly a people person in the film
Lord Farquaad has the aloneness
intimidate the magic mirror on the wall
by holding up and punching a handheld
mirror and shatters and Lord Farquaad
looks at the magic mirror as if to say
this could be you if you don't tell me
what I want to hear Polonius also nearly
drowns the gingerbread man by dunking
his head in a glass of milk so why is
the executioner so antisocial could it
be that he is actually an ogre
redditor ninja bread man thinks so ninja
bread man points out that the
executioner is almost the same size as
Shrek but it's kind of hard to tell for
sure since they aren't seen standing
next to each other and if you look at
the skin beneath the eye holes of his
executioner hood it does have a pea soup
green color add to the fact that this
guy does not play well with others and
you've got a recipe for a potential ogre
what do you think
Oh grrrrrr or giant angry human some of
you may die but it's a sacrifice I am
willing to make set in a
post-apocalyptic future there's a theory
about the Shrek realm that is pretty out
there but it's so interesting we had to
include it reddit user party tracks
thinks that the entire shrek verse
including all four movies takes place
thousands of years into the future this
fan theorizes that this whimsical
satirical fairytale world has emerged
from the ashes of a post nucular frenzy
which has ravaged the entire planet with
all that radiation in the atmosphere and
makes the existence of temperamental
green ogres and stalking donkeys totally
feasible when spider-man received a tiny
bite from a radioactive spider he became
a web wielding superhero overnight so
just imagine what a planet infested by
radiation could do this fan thinks the
society in Strack was the result of a
sort of patchwork rebuilding of
civilization which incorporates a bunch
of literary and pop-culture references
and since everything was wiped out
survivors of the Armageddon clung to as
many pop-culture references as they
could they then passed them on to future
mutated generations this theory has been
around about other popular movies but in
this case it doesn't seem completely
impossible
[Music]
the ultimate cabin fever fiona is an
amazing resourceful princess with
ninja-like abilities so it's easy to
forget that she's been locked inside of
a tower for a long time like really long
like long enough to make any sane person
lose their marbles Reddit user lego
brick er came up with a few theories of
his own while watching Shrek The Musical
according to the musical fiona was
locked up in that tower for 23 years
guarded by a fire-breathing dragon no
matter how good your own company is that
much time alone would drive anybody
completely bonkers in fact there is a
scientific research proving that
solitary confinement deteriorates the
mind stability after only about 30 days
fiona was confined alone in that tower
for 276 months lego brick earth thinks
that fiona would certainly have started
hallucinating at some point it seems
obvious that her hallucinations would
include being rescued from that tower
but since she's turning a little batty
her visions involve a green ogre and a
talking donkey naturally so an unstable
Fiona turned her prince charming into a
green ogre who has an annoying talking
donkey instead of a valiant steed
so did Fiona imagine the entire
storyline somebody get dr. Phil on the
phone
[Music]
I don't know we could do that mama bear
we've got to warn you this next theory
is dark seriously clear your schedule
for an hour-long session of crying and
ice cream eating before you go any
further with this one it has to do with
Lord Farquaad and the three bears if you
recall at the beginning of the first
Shrek movie we meet a wide variety of
fairy tale characters there's a moment
when we see the three bears locked in
cages baby bears in a cage all by
himself and he is crying while his
parents look at him from a bigger cage
that in itself is sad enough to ruin
anyone's day but it gets only worse
later on in the film when Shrek goes
back to a swamp there are a few fairy
tale characters hanging out on the
grounds papa bear and baby bear can be
seen snuggling up together by the fire
but mama bear is nowhere to be found
so where did Mama Bear go the answer is
horrifying
reddit user ex-mormon Phoenix showed a
picture from lord farquaad's bedroom in
the film on the floor is a bearskin rug
with the same bow on its head as the one
mama bear was wearing in the first scene
that Farquaad is a horrible person
that'll do donkey that'll do the ogre
apocalypse one fan thinks that our
favorite grumpy overs existence actually
caused the ogre race to come close to
extinction predator el lucas explains
that instruct to the king hires Puss in
Boots to get rid of Shrek because he is
a professional ochre exterminator this
fan draws the conclusion that Shrek must
be the only living ochre except for
Fiona who is actually human during
daylight hours in the first film we
never see any ogres until strike four
when Fiona rescues herself from the
tower and turns puss and boots into a
fat lazy house gap with Puss in Boots
out of commission as the ogre Eliminator
there is a whole village full of living
ogres they were never hunted down by
Puss in Boots in this alternate reality
then when the timeline is restored to
the original version where Shrek exists
and is married to Fiona all the other
ochres are gone because they were hunted
down by the skinny agile version of puss
and boots
so if Shrek had never existed all the
other overs would still be alive this is
a super morbid theory
who knew shrek fans could be so dark
odors are like onions
end of story bye-bye which fan theory
was your favorite are there any we
overlooked if so tell us in the comment
section below give this video a big
thumbs up if you love talking donkeys
and while you're at it hit that
subscribe button to be the first in line
for our newest videos thanks for
watching and see you next time on the
things
[Music]